DANIEL WAISBERG: Google
Analytics best practices,
or analytics in
general best practices.
And first of all, I'd
like to talk a little bit
about snooker.
I know that we are in the UK
and some people like snooker,
especially as we had the world
championship just this week.
And one of the things,
I was born in Brazil.
And back then, when I was
a teenager, that's the way
we thought about snooker, right.
It's a place where you go
to smoke and drink beer.
And playing snooker is
just to kill the time.
And that's what we thought.
And just going to--
MALE SPEAKER: Paul
Newman, Tom Cruise
in a Martin Scorsese picture.
FAST EDDIE FELSON: He's got
the eye, he's got the stroke,
he's got the flick.
CARMEN: Vince is the best.
[FIGHTING NOISES]
FAST EDDIE FELSON: We got a
race horse here, a thoroughbred.
You make him feel good,
I teach him how to run.
I'm not your daddy,
I'm not your boyfriend.
So don't be playing
games with me.
I'm your partner.
DANIEL WAISBERG: So that's the
way I thought about snooker.
And then a new chapter
started in my life.
I moved to Israel
and got married.
And my brother-in-law,
that's him.
He's a professional
snooker player.
And lately, he started teaching
us how to play snooker.
And there are some amazing
things in this game.
And it's a very smart game.
And you need a very
special technique.
You need to understand
the physics about the game
and how to pocket balls.
And you can make money.
I don't know how many of you
know this Mr. O'Sullivan.
He has been the champion for
the last, I think, five years.
And he won 7.5 million pounds
in just professional games.
But not all of us can be
professional snooker players.
So I'm going to talk a little
bit about how to use analytics
in a professional way.
So as opposed to
using it as an amateur
and going to play snooker
just to kill time,
I'm going to talk about
being a professional snooker
player using analytics.
So first, I'd like to talk
about web analytics, what's
the overall objective
of analytics.
And I like this chart.
It's from the '90s-- a
friend of mine, Jim Sterne.
And he's also the owner
of the eMetrics Summit.
And what I think
as you can see, it
goes from top left
to bottom right.
And you can see the
three dotted lines.
First one is
acquisition, persuasion,
and then conversion.
So what we see on
the top left chart
is that we are acquiring
lots of people.
And they are very untargeted.
So we don't manage to
persuade them to look
at the [? effort, ?] to
sign up, or to buy something
on the website, correct.
And then as you understand
better the customers,
you can convince them to
get deeper into the product
and maybe purchase
something from the website.
And the last one, you
can see that maybe you
have less people, but they're
much more targeted so you're
bringing the right
people to the website.
Now, this is a web analytics
process that I like to use.
And I think it's a good one.
And I emphasize that it's
a web analytics process.
It's not the web
analytics process.
So basically, what we need
to do is first of all,
we need to define the
goals of the website.
And that's not as
simple as it might seem.
I mean, sometimes the website
is about selling something.
So selling is the ultimate
objective, so the macro goal.
And then there are all
kinds of micro goals,
which is getting people to
sign up for a newsletter,
getting people to
follow you on Google+.
And then, once you
define the goals,
you start defining the KPIs,
which are the key performance
indicators.
So they are the
numbers that you will
use to measure if you're
succeeding with your goals
or not.
And once you have
those two things,
you can start
collecting the data.
So people usually, they start
from collecting the data.
And then they look at
what they're collecting.
So first of all,
define the goals.
Then building KPIs and
collecting the data.
Once you have all the data,
you start analyzing it.
Sometimes, you'll
start analyzing,
and then you'll go
back to collecting
because you don't have
everything you need.
After you analyze, you have
to do something with it.
So usually, the
best way to proceed
is building a test,
an A/B test, and then
testing different alternatives,
see which one is better.
Once you do that, you
implement the changes.
And then you can go back
to analyzing or revisiting
the whole process.
So that's more or less
the [? valid ?] analytics
process that you
should think about.
But as a startup, I
think it's very important
to understand that
you need to use
the process that works for you.
So sometimes you might go look
at the data, first of all,
and see what you have and
what you can do with it.
And then you can start
thinking about the analysis.
So I'm going to talk
about four principles
that I think every company
should keep in mind when
they use Google Analytics.
And they are very
important for everything
you do when managing
the website.
So first one trends.
So this is a data point.
And a data point
is not very useful.
So if you know that yesterday
you had 5,000 visitors
and they brought 10,000
pounds in revenue,
it's not very useful.
So you need to-- oops.
Sorry.
You need to compare how
it's growing, right.
Is it growing, or
is it going down?
And that's a very
important thing.
And if you are in a seasonal
business-- like travel,
for example-- you
should compare, not only
see if it's growing.
You should also
see if it's growing
as opposed to the
same season last year.
So if you look at
summer, for example,
you can't compare
summer to winter.
So you should compare
summer to last summer.
That's a very important point.
Now is there Ernest
Hemingway-- "There's
nothing noble in being
superior to your fellow man;
true nobility is being
superior to your former self."
So it's very important.
Lots of people, they
are always trying
to compare themselves
with others.
And I think the
first thing should
be to compare yourself to
what you have been last year
or before.
Now thinking about trends,
I think trends is very good
and it's very important.
But trends is not enough.
So you should also
look at segmentation.
And meaning-- so if you're
looking at how my website grew
in the last three months, you
should also look, drill down
into what kind of segments
drove this growth.
So there are two
types of segmentation.
And the first one is top-down.
The second one is bottom-up.
So top-down personas
is something
that you decide-- the management
decides-- and then tells
everyone to do
what they decided.
Then there's the
data driven, which
is the analyst discovers
a pattern in the data
and then tells
everyone about it.
So the analyst is
usually the lowest
you can get in the organization.
Now, personas, just
to talk a little bit.
Basically, what we
do is you sit down,
and you think about what kind of
people you're trying to target.
So let's suppose
I'm trying my users
should be someone like
Daniel, a fictional person.
He commutes from Cambridge
to London every day.
He reads his email on the train.
And he reads "The Guardian."
And then we start.
You give a picture
to this persona.
And you start creating people
that you want to target them.
So there's Daniel,
and there's James,
and there's Jonathan,
or other people.
And once you do that, you can
create a website based on that.
And we know that there are
four main types of personas.
So there's logical, impulsive,
caring, and aggressive.
So logical are
people that they're
looking for information.
So they want to know
everything there
is to know about the product.
There are impulsive people.
So if they see something
nice on the website,
they will just buy right away.
There's caring people, which
is people that care about what
other people say.
And aggressive people
that they're just
looking for the best deal.
So we know, for
example, that Apple
that they are in the
upper side of this chart.
So they're very
logical, because they
provide you lots of information
about their products.
And impulsive, because
they designed the website
so that people will
feel good about it,
and they'll purchase something.
And Amazon is on the
bottom of this chart, which
is they have ratings and
reviews, which people use
a lot to buy a product.
And they're very aggressive
in terms of pricing.
Now, if we talk
about data driven,
which is what we analysts
we do is analyzing the data
and trying to find patterns
that will give you information
to provide a better
experience to your visitors.
So on Google Analytics, we
have the segment builder.
So if I start seeing
that people coming
on Saturdays and from
the United States,
they have a very
high conversion rate.
And they're spending lots
of money on websites.
So I should take this
segment and start
optimizing the website for them.
So everyone that comes from
the United States on Saturdays
should get specific website,
personalized website.
So that's segmentation.
"I abhor averages."
So a person that eats six meals
one day and zero the next day
and a person that eats
three meals one day
and three the other day, they
both have a three meal average
a day.
But of course, it's
not the same thing.
And so never ever look
at the aggregate data.
So every time that you
log into Google Analytics,
you should definitely look
into segments or your customers
so that you understand what
is good for each of them
and what's bad for each of
them so that you can optimize
the website, or personalize
the website for your visitors.
Now, something that is really
important to Google Analytics
is context, right.
So we have a way to
annotate the data.
So we have this data.
You can see a
spike on the chart.
And what happened on that day?
So of course, if it was a week
ago, I can look for someone
and just find out what
happened last week
that we have this huge spike.
So if I'm looking
at last year's data.
So I won't know what happened
that day, especially,
for example, if there was an
offline event, if you presented
on a big conference
or something.
Of course, if it is there
was a post on TechCrunch
about the website, you
can find it on the data.
Because you know people
are referring traffic
to your website.
But if it was an
offline data, or maybe
there was a hosting problem.
And not in this specific one,
but if you have a down day,
you could write, for example,
that the server was down.
So those are things that
you can't see on the data.
Now, another way to enrich
data, to provide context.
So if I have this
website, Banana
Republic that I'm
selling clothes.
And as you can see here,
they have a customer.
By the way, default
implementation on Google
Analytics.
You would see just
which page you're in
and what happened on this
page, how long people stayed
on that page, what was the
bounce rate of this page,
and this kind of information.
Now, there is a whole lot
more to learn about this page.
And what Banana
Republic they have,
for example, they have
different types of models.
So they have a white model,
they have a black model,
and they have an Asian model.
So there are three people.
And then they have shirts where
the default is black and shirts
where the default is gray.
And they have shirts for men,
shirts for women of course.
And all kinds of information.
Now, what we can do, we
can take this customer ID.
And of course, I have this
customer ID in my database.
And with all this current
data that I'm talking about.
And now, what I can do,
I can upload this table
into Google Analytics.
And then I'll have
all the information
available to make decisions.
And then suddenly, I will
be able to answer questions.
Like what's the conversion
rate of this model?
What's the conversion
rate, for example,
of pique shirts as
opposed to vintage shirts?
And should the default
be black or gray?
So I can start answering
more instant questions
based on website behavior
and the information
that I have on my database.
So this is a very good
way to enrich data
in Google Analytics.
And you can upload
also anything that you
have in your CRM
into Google Analytics
using dimension widening.
So that's a very important
feature to keep in mind.
Now, cost data upload.
Some people for
some reason, they
use platforms other than Google.
I don't understand why.
I mean, everyone should be
using AdWords to advertise.
But there are some people
that use other tools,
like Bing and Twitter and
Facebook and LinkedIn.
So they advertise
on those tools.
And it's very, very easy
to take your campaigns
so that you know when people
are coming to the website
through, for example, LinkedIn.
So if you don't do that, it's
really important if you're
building marketing campaigns,
it should tag your links.
So just look for
Google Analytics
campaign tagging on Google.
But once you do that, and
it's a very easy step,
you will start learning what
kind of things people coming
from LinkedIn, for example,
they're doing on the website.
So how many people
came to the website?
What was the bounce rate?
How long did they
stay on the website?
How much did they
buy on the website?
What was the revenue
of this campaign?
Now there is one very
important thing missing,
which is how much does it cost?
Because if I don't
know how much it costs,
it dropped 50,000
pounds in revenue.
But if it cost
100,000 pounds, it's
different from if it
costs 5,000 pounds.
So what we have on
Google Analytics now
is called cost data upload.
So you can upload
your cost data.
That's exactly what you can do.
So you just upload the
table into Google Analytics
that can enrich your campaign.
So it gives you context
on your marketing efforts.
So it's really important
to change Google Analytics
into a marketing optimization
tool for all campaigns.
And just to mention,
of course, we
have integration
with Google AdWords.
So that would be different.
You don't have to
upload anything.
Now the last one, sharing.
Because sharing is caring.
So we just published a blog
post on big black smoke
with a few things at the can
share on Google Analytics
and I think it's there.
That's something that we believe
it's really, really important
is to share data
with your colleagues.
Because each person
has a perspective.
Each person knows something
about the company.
And it's really important
that everyone sees the data
and knows what's happening.
So we have a few things.
I'm going through all of them.
And then I won't get too
deep into any of them.
So first one segments, as
I mentioned previously,
the segment builder.
You can build segments.
So if you have, for example, you
build a segment of people that
came to the website,
added something to a cart,
and then left the website,
and came back to the website,
you can build multiple
visit segments.
And then you have
something really important,
because you're building a
segment that means something
to people in your company.
So you can share this
segment with your colleagues
to just send them a link.
And then they will see that
on there Google Analytics
account as well.
Second one's dashboards.
So if you build
a nice dashboard,
you want to share with your
manager or your colleagues
so that they see the
same data, they're
tracking the same data as you
on a daily basis, hopefully
a weekly basis.
And third one's custom reports.
So you can build in Google
Analytics custom reports.
So if you have
this table that you
can choose the
dimensions that you want
and then the metrics
that you want to see,
those that are important to you.
And you can share
these so that people
look at the same numbers as you.
Goals.
So when you have multiple
views in your Google Analytics
account, you can share
goals so that you
have the same goal defined
in each of your views.
So that's a very
important thing as well.
Now, custom channel
groupings is something
that you see on the
multi-channel funnels.
So you can see on
Google Analytics,
for example, that when
people came to the website
multiple times
before conversion.
So for example, they
came through social, then
through organic, and then
through a paid campaign,
you can see all the
steps that draw people
until they converted.
And what you can do with
custom channel groupings is,
for example, you have
different websites
that you want to group them into
specific campaign, for example.
So you could use channel
groupings to do that.
And then you can share with
your colleagues as well for them
to see the same data
that you're seeing.
An attribution
models is something
that I'm not going to talk too
much about attribution models.
It's a subject by itself.
But basically, attribution
is about giving credit
to campaigns that brought
people to your website.
So basically, if you
advertise something and then
people come to the website,
and they come back again
in a few weeks using
Google organic.
And then in a few
weeks they come again
using an email that
you send to them,
then you can use attribution
to provide credit
to each of those source that
brought people to the website.
And you can create a
custom attribution model
that you can use based on what
you know about your visitors,
and how each campaign
added to a conversion.
So some take aways.
First of all, create a process.
So create something that
works for a company.
There are multiple models.
And you can find on Google
search, multiple models
that you can use
for web analytics.
Look at trends.
Don't look at data points.
So when you look at the data,
always look at at least one
of the rules of
thumb that I like
is looking at least
for-- first of all
looking in weekly periods.
Because sometimes, there's
a very big difference
between middle of the
week and end of the week.
So always to look at weeks.
And I like the rule
as well that look
at four plus one, which means
a little bit more than a month,
or a little bit
more than a year.
So 13 months or five weeks.
Segment your customers.
First, there are multiple ways
to do that on Google Analytics.
And you can create views.
You can create
custom dimensions.
You can build the segments.
So there are multiple ways.
And try to segment
every time that you
log into Google Analytics.
Then enrich your data.
So I mentioned Google
Analytics annotations,
dimension widening, and
of course data upload.
Those are three ways
that you can enrich data
so that it will have more
context for you to analyze.
And sharing is caring.
It's really important to share
the data with your colleagues
so that everyone
in the organization
knows-- the startup--
knows about what's going on
with the data, how is the
company going, and-- thank you.
And happy analyzing.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
DANIEL WAISBERG: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Does anyone
have questions?